he could have you know found God changed
you know decided to like become a good
father to make a man so whatever it
might be but to use and I know that now
by saying this I'm just too far for real
all right the forgot the headphone that
was [ __ ] good oh yeah you crop-dusted
us many a couple times warns us what can
somebody grab a sorry that was rude
well I mean that's you know sweet drink
when you're with your wife do you fart
in the bed I don't actually don't fart
white pants they were brown with white
clothes they came out white so you don't
you don't fart in the bed
everyone farts in the bed you can't
control your sleeping you've heart in
the bed I understand that J but don't
forget argumentative what I'm asking is
that no I'm modest I'm a you know yeah I
keep it I keep my my things you know
away from noses
I have to say J is very he's very like
polite he's got very good etiquette
about things like he'll go to the bath
he's like if you're on set whatever
he'll go to the bathroom
well that could go away from everyone to
like blow his nose even yeah oh yeah
he'll like go away like he's got a thing
like quite plainly yeah yeah that's
that's true yeah doesn't like other
people's like saliva or that if you'd
fought if you phone my friend Sebastian
has a a towel a wet towel next to his
bed Sebastian Maniscalco I've heard this
story and I'm just gonna say that is way
more disgusting than any other strat
fart strategy strategy to to lessen the
the smell and to you know into it soften
the blow a wet towel that he has like
next to him right he'll pull it out
he'll stick it between his little
Italian butt cheeks being outed right
it's okay a lot of people and I don't
see it so just I'm being good right now
guys and he he muffles it like a like a
gun you know the gun right and it
dead-ends the smell and it's it's good
for his wife Lana I think that's polite
it's charcoal filtered well your
boyfriend doesn't fart in front of you
what's wrong with me babe you know is it
because I don't have I think you got
stuck in one of you earlier um
Erikson's stages yes yeah it start
there's like there's a there's like a
feet fecal yeah age right
he's he's gone through the same thing
where he holds his poo intentionally for
pleasure when I was a not anymore no
[Laughter]
wait I remember I was like eight years
old and I remember my grandparents I was
living that with the town we're looking
for me and they called my mom we can't
find him where is he where is he I don't
know he didn't leave the house so they
kept searching and they found me under a
grand piano in a plank position like
this completely drenched in sweat
shaking and smiling its cultural yeah I
don't know about the sweating maybe back
then didn't have Nintendo switches and
stuff for kids that was my game I told
them okay hold your aid 80 years old
yeah